les ca banfield a témoigné pendant
plusieurs heures devant la commission
des pertes massives et devant environ
150 personnes dont plusieurs familles de
victimes entouré de ses soeurs la voix
tremblante elle est revenue sur les
violences qu'elle a subies au cours des
19 ans de vie de couple avec le tueur
l'avocate de la commission lui a demandé
pourquoi elle n'a pas signalé à la
police qu'il avait obtenu illégalement
des armes à feu et menacé de s'en servir
elle a répondu qu'elle avait peur
elle a raconté un épisode où il l'a
menacée avec un pistolet elle était
persuadé qu'il était capable de la tuer
quand la police a frappé à la porte de
leur appartement de dartmouth en 2010
après une plainte pour menaces de mort
elle a menti en disant que son conjoint
n'avait pas d'armes à feu chez lui car
elle craignait qu'ils se mettent à tirer
depuis leur chambre à coucher at elle
dit
l'avocat du a aussi demandé si elle
soupçonnait que gabriel ousmane était
capable de commettre une tuerie comme
celle des 18 et 19 avril 2020
les cévennes feared a répondu qu'il
racontait souvent des bêtises y compris
qu'il voulait mourir de façon
spectaculaire mais elle n'y prêtais pas
attention et quitter la pièce les sapins
deux firmes se souvient aussi que le
tueur conduisait parfois un ancien
véhicule de la grc qui n'avait plus de
bandes réfléchissantes sur les côtés
mais qu'ils étaient suffisamment
impressionnant pour que les gens
s'écartent sur son passage en revanche
contrairement à ce qu'a dit un autre
témoin elle assure qu'elle ne l'a jamais
vu conduire la copie presque conforme
d'une autopatrouille qu'il a utilisé
pendant la tuerie d'avril 2020
je ne sais pas s'il y sa belle fille
roman si elle dit la vérité ou si elles
se trompent a dit l'avocat d'une
majorité des familles de victimes
insatisfaite du témoignage d'aujourd'hui
son équipe évalue maintenant une autre
procédure judiciaire pour obtenir des
réponses de lisbonne perdent ici adrien
blanc radio canada à halifax